telling us about the future of genomic
research is going to be crowned sourcing
okay thanks um so I have I guess a
number of confessions to make the start
so I don't know what crowdsourcing is
but it sounds cool so I guess we do it
so I guess the other confession is about
population genetics I've always kind of
felt you know population genetics you
know it's a field of you know pretty
smart people working on relatively
interesting problems with just
absolutely no data right isn't you know
by you know just so I this talk is going
to be exactly the opposite of that in
all hopefully not in all three
directions but um it's it's it's it's
it's going to be a bunch of simple
questions that you can answer with with
a very very large amount of data here
the other confession is that this is
really you know because I wanted to talk
about new things that you know kind of
know I'm up in berkeley it heard about
before this is this is essentially all
others peoples work and you know in much
of it as kind of half-baked at this
point okay so so so just start out I i
feel kind of an obligation coming from
23 me to talk for just a second about
risk and and and genetics genetics
disease risk and so on so right now if
if all of you in the room got genotype
something like half of you would find
out one of these perhaps the pressing
perhaps empowering you know things on
this on this list you know more than
half if you're Ashkenazi less than half
if you're Asian probably but you know
this disorder sort of order of magnitude
twenty percent of you will find out that
you are at you know three times
increased risk of developing Alzheimer's
disease for example and that those
effects are probably showing up even in
your thirties forties already so so so
so this is right now this is actually
probably even about two years ago this
you know this was true and five years
from now this will not be fifty percent
this will be 89 d you know 99 percent
right okay so that that is I guess a
brief glimpse of the future and you know
I'm something going to make for very
very very
show assertions I guess so that you know
that the this the first one so okay so
so so so it happens in G once you find a
lot of signals a very small effect you
find a lot of signals that all have odds
ratios of about 1.1 and you know and
then and then someone says well 1.1 that
doesn't mean anything you know that's
you know that's increasing my risk by
ten percent whatever that's the same as
me going out and having a slice of cake
during break and actually uh there's a
Stanford professor who said exactly that
i want you know i want more mission to
his name but anyhow so it turns out that
if you know if you add a bunch of small
things together well you multiply you
know a bunch of these odds ratios
together you can get something that is
big okay so that's you know if you have
a hundred snips that are have all been
found associated with the disease they
all have an odds ratio of 1.1 you have
20 more risk alleles than non risk
alleles you could be a pretty high risk
okay so the second point is if i gave
you risk predictions across 40 different
diseases say essentially everyone will
be in the top 5% of one of those you
know one of those predictions right
we're all at high risk for something the
you know the the the third point you
know i guess it's kind of directed
towards the fda but you know people deal
with a lot of you know a lot of kind of
crappy things in life not always with
the medical doctors help and then and
then this is actually live on the
Internet sorry
sorry so so you know the yeah the last
point here is you know is that you know
okay so so you can't you can't be
changing your DNA or so on but you do it
you do have the nice interpretability
here of the DNA is kind of clearly
causal these you know these you know you
know these these snips you know uh you
know up to some details they're actually
causing the disease the disease is not
causing these you know these these
different alleles so this is this is
both better and worse than traditional
epidemiology where you know high
cholesterol and and and heart attack
risk well this is you know is a truly
causal is it not I mean it's certainly
something you can intervene on but is
interviewing audit going to help and so
on okay so okay so four points about
risk and you talk then just a little
kind of key things is very very light at
first so it turns out for the Olympics
we asked a bunch of people what what
sports they played and this is the the
lines the lines show up a little bit
this this is a spectral clustering the
cool you know the correlation matrix
between what sports people play so these
these are not my labels but you know
you've got the you've got the you know
the way lifting in the elliptical
machine cluster over here yet you've got
the young people sports the and you know
so it turns out you you you you you
actually pull out a lot of structure
just by asking a lot of people a
question and and doing something very
dumb so so so then it turns out we've
got something like 25,000 trios in the
23 me database and so we looked again
for Valentine's Day we looked at you
know what what factors are making people
couples so we looked at hla similarity
and found found kind of completely no
results there if you look across
different phenotypes it turns out that
couples tend to both be punctual they
both both b skiers pikers both we
non-smokers fast food lovers or both be
kind of you know apology proin but
they're there a couple of traits that go
on the different in the opposite
direction so it turns out that that
people who wake up early and people
go to bed late are you know tend to tend
to be attracted to each other or perhaps
this is I I don't know the rector of
causality perhaps after you get married
you start to avoid your spouse this yeah
so okay okay so but but then the the
interesting question is what happens
with your you know with with with with
with your kids right so you know
so-and-so heritability is kind of the
you know the you know I mean especially
when you have kids and you're you're
trying to assign proper blame for things
between you and your spouse you'd like
to know what what to do so this is this
is joined with with Breeland Brown their
practice student here Aaron climate Nick
flaw timid Pearson who are all at 23 me
I should mention that so in pearson we
are unfortunately going to lose to grad
school she is terrifyingly smart and I I
would like her to find a good home
actually so yes so so if there is
someone in someone in computer science
who would do you know who would would
like to try and convince her to come
please let me know okay so so so so
we've computed heritability numbers
these are these are these are
heritabilities across various disease
traits so this is cut off a little bit
but you have pigmentation traits you
have immune traits like allergies you
have food preferences various metabolic
traits cancer traits morphology hair
neurological are not on so these these
are heritabilities in in in europeans
computed with GCT a actually so this is
heritable e-tank by common steps and and
and and you do see you know somewhat the
pattern that you'd expect your
pigmentation traits are you know are
very heritable so on um it turns out
that if you if yep these traits yes
thank you yes okay so if it it turns out
so I I've been working for five six
years now trying to figure out how to
give an interest and talk about G wasps
other than here's you know here's some
steps there associate
with the disease so I'm going to kind of
entirely skip that it turns out that
more heritable conditions we find more
hits for so these are the number of
significant associations in the 23
database I guess square root to make it
look a little bit more linear and the
more heritable traits such as height you
know I color for examples see a lot of a
lot of hits you you can see although
this is somewhat confounded by sample
size you can see some difference in in
kind of genetic architecture right where
height is you know can kind of known to
be the sum of you know a lot of very
very small effects I color there are a
handful of snips here that explain a
very large percentage of the variance in
an eye color so so so we've been doing
this across populations so most of the
results aren't aren't aren't ready
unfortunately these these are the you
know however in blue these are the
African heritability estimates in red
these are the European heritability
estimates use you see a few differences
but they are mostly so this is this is
not quite readable but but this is
freckling this is hair color these these
are two of the biggest differences and
this this is probably not a real
difference but but simply uh you know
kind of a problem with with interpreting
heritability in an ad mixed population
right so in among african-americans your
your Franklin propensity or your hair
color is really determined entirely by
how much how much European how much
European DNA you have right okay so okay
so I so the these these are a few things
that we've been working on this morning
so so so so the broad idea here is that
we're trying to compute heritability
across hundreds of different traits in a
few different ways all with different
biases and and in particular you know
well you know one of the things you can
do is take all of the trio's you could
get a heritability number there and that
heritability number is going to include
your shared environment right so you
know if you know if you just look at the
correlations between the kids trades and
the parents
it's that is a you know kind of you know
a heritable t plus plus shared
environment estimate and and and they're
a bunch of things that were kind of
trying to puzzle out here which I assume
are mostly are mostly due to environment
but also due to the short environment
but I kind of can't explain all of them
so for example four daughters their BMI
and their height are much more strongly
correlated with their mothers heightened
be my than their fathers so you know and
and for both sons and daughters their
diet and political views are more
strongly correlated with their mothers
diet and political views than their
fathers and the opposite for you know
for smoking so so so so most of these
you can kind of you know it's going your
eyes a little bit and say okay this is
this makes sense with shared environment
I don't know how to explain the height
result it seems to be its it seems to be
significant it seems to be yes I don't
know if there's actual possible genetic
mechanism here or if or what's going on
with that but ideas would be would be
helpful um okay so so now talk you know
have a little bit of math in the in the
stock so is so this this this project
this is this is with eric granted corey
mclean started off actually when we
started trying to use long-range phasing
to phase all of the 23 me data set so so
we're now at six seven hundred thousand
people in the data set about ninety
percent of them are european and and so
at that you know at that number if you
compute IBD down to say to Santa Morgan
segments you you actually expect to have
enough segment so that every person will
have kind of surrogate parents at every
point in their it you know in in their
genome enough so that you can
essentially perfectly face them so it
turns out that our our tree are our
long-range phasing algorithm worked
really well in in simulations and really
poorly in practice so we started to to
ask to ask why that is and so and so
should just say this so right so this
this so if you have if you have people
that are computationally phase you
probably have say a switch error every
sinner Morgan right and so you are
looking for IBD segments that are much
longer than sinner Morgan so you're
you're likely to see switch errors in
there so you're likely to see some
pattern like this and if you're running
IBD on half a million people the only
you know in any way feasible way to you
know to do this is to use germline right
you cannot you you get you you you can't
be using beagle you yeah it's just it's
just kind of impossible so what so what
your line is doing right and it's you
know in its and it's it small here is
it's taking all of these all of all of
these blue segments as seeds if there
long enough and then it's sliding along
and trying to extend them unless it hits
you know an opposite almost I get and if
you get a long enough segments there you
reported as a potential IBD segment I'm
right then so it can it can go through
and correct those those switch errors
and so so what we did is we looked in in
trios and the you know the trivial
observation right that if you have an
IBD segment between the kid and some
other person then it it better be IBD
between either you know you know either
either either the dad or the mom and
that other person okay so so so what we
did pulled so you know we actually only
used something like ten percent of the
trio's because there was so many ivd
segments but ok so we pulled three
thousand trios some seventeen other
thousand Europeans red germline and
everybody in this and so i should say
everyone here is you know is just
computationally faced with with beagle
so it so it turns out you get a lot of
segments most of those segments are are
short there's a total of something like
like 13 million segments this was only
on a couple of chromosomes and and our
measure of correctness here was just how
many how many informative sites are are
are shared between the IBD statements
right so here this this this brown
segment is the child other IBD segment
and the and similarly this this mother
segment and this father segments are the
mother father other IBD segments so here
the you know the the mother has you know
can 55 shared ones out of out of 9 I
guess it's and so and so here we you
know we give this segment a score of you
know fifty five percent of you know
fifty-five percent overlap okay so that
that that's that if you look across all
the about 13 million child other
segments that we found on these
chromosomes well a lot a lot of them
show very very little overlap so so 61
percent of them showed no overlap at all
you know so there's no parental segment
that is you know that's overlapping at
all another twenty-five percent are
showing a little bit and fourteen
percent of them seem really good so if
we look at these truncated these these
these truncated segments and go back and
see are these are these actually good
calls you know we see that we're calling
the you know the opposite homozygous
that is truncating this segment we're
calling it with with with you know with
high confidence almost all the time yeah
these were these were trails detected by
IBD yes and there was yes they were I
don't know if they knew where they were
trios but they were true yeah okay but
so it's so okay so it's it's it's it's
it's not a case of genotyping error
causing false false negative parent IVD
here and so also if you look at these at
these at these segments that show no
overlap well they all you know they
almost all show a lot of a lot of
opposite homozygotes in in the parents
right so you know so you know so we're
really confident that these you know
that you know that that is that this
measure is you know is correct and that
we're not actually
you know seeing a you know a ton of
false-negative parent IBD and this you
know this is kind of correlates with how
germline is too and right to give you a
you know to you know to find a lot of
segments of you know of which not all of
them might be perfect so we so okay so
this this is this this is average
overlap and it says cut off sorry okay
sorry so this so so so so you see that
segments above you know four or five
cent of organs they are almost all red
which is you know said essentially kind
of perfect overlap the you know and you
know but but the the average overlap for
all of these two to four Santa Morgan
segments is very very low there's some
there's some artifacts because we're
doing this on small chromosomes so you
see you know the segment's going through
the centromere and this one I don't know
actually I so there's there's there's
some filtering actually that went on
before this you know to throw our
regions of low snip-snip density and you
know in regions of you know regions that
just show these very very big peaks of
IBD I'm kind of guessing that we missed
a couple of those okay so okay so so and
we just chose eighty percent as kind of
an arbitrary threshold for what is true
the results are robust and and so and so
we wanted to score these a little bit
more reasonably so let me give you an
example here right so if if we have you
know so if we have these two individuals
here we could either say that these are
this that they share they share this
segment IBD with a total of three
switchers across there or we could
alternatively just say that there are
two genotyping errors that were leading
to this so it
you probably see where this is going
we're going to give a cost to a you know
22 germ line allowing a switch error
cost the germ line allowing a genotyping
error it turns out to really not matter
much what you know what what the cost
you know what the cost is but here yeah
we we went through an estimated switch
r-rated genotyping error rate it and and
and and and gave this this this Apple
score as you know as as you know some of
how many things that you are you know
how many swisher summary junior typing
errors you're requiring for this to be
to be IBD it turns out this can be
solved efficiently with with dynamic
programming which is probably something
one should not go through late on a
Friday afternoon but you know this this
this this can be solved this this can be
computed easily enough so it turns out
the you know the the nice thing is is
that this hapless core is very
discriminative so here the here the
y-axis here is is our computer hapless
core on segment by by genetic length the
red segments are the good ones the blue
ones are are the bad ones and you can
see a really clear delineation here
between between good and bad segments
according to the hapless core so
theoretically this this line probably
should web as part of this curve here
probably should actually be a line
there's a little bit of weirdness in the
in the kind of two to two-and-a-half
cinemark and range because of the fact
that we detected everything with a to
cinemark and cut off and then we're
using this kind of eighty percent
coverage feature you know over and over
so really I think I'm results should be
kind of valid from two and a half cent
of organs up or something but it so it
turns out that you know that you can
efficiently throw out the you know the
you know the the the millions of
segments that are wrong this the this
works been kind of you know this works
on other chromosomes this works in a few
other in a few other data sets that we
get so okay so so so we can
we can do that with with IBD let me talk
a little bit then about you know about
the history of America I guess this is
so this is this is this is kasha brick
eric grant joanna mountain mostly doing
this so the the data set here is about
about 170,000 people who are living in
the US and who gave us self-identified
ethnicity so as either European Latino
or african-american this set so okay so
all so so so when I use any of those
terms now I'm going to mean
self-identified ethnicity and then and
then we have a local ancestry assignment
method that you know using either 25 or
26 different countries or regions so
these these are the are the regions
along with the kind of training sizes
these are these are trained using HD GDP
data plus a lot of 23andme data from
customers who reported having four four
grandparents who are aqua nosy or you
know or from one of these one of these
given countries so this this this local
ancestor method works works fairly well
I'm not going to talk about it but it's
interesting to see how that interacts
with with self-reported ethnicity so
this is these these plots here hopefully
are readable these are for for
african-americans so this this is the
this is plotting up here this is me an
African ancestry by state of the state
of button by state of birth I think we
have we have both state of birth and
current current residents but I think
all of this is state of birth so you
know so you see that african-americans
in the south you know have have higher
average mean African ancestry than then
african-americans California for example
so here the here are the two
distributions and that there's a
non-trivial proportion of you know of
Native American ancestry in you know in
the in the African Americans
okay so similarly if we do this across
across Latinos so this is the okay so
this this is this is the same plot of
you know how much American ancestry much
Native American ancestry you see for the
self-identified Latinos by state and
also the total the the projection down
on to just just European African and
north and Native American components I
guess of the you know their genome-wide
% % 4 for the Latinos and now the the
hidden part of this is you know is
looking actually at people who
self-identify as Europeans all right so
here are these these are you know the
frequency of Europeans with at least two
percent African ancestry the frequency
of Europeans with the least to present
Native American ancestry and you see
this is this is really quite high so
this tops out at about five percent in
South Carolina and Louisiana you know
you know similarly in the southwest and
the most of the West for you know for
that for you know for the Native
American ancestry so this means that you
know so I i think the total nationwide
is something like one point eight
percent of self-identified europeans in
in the 23 me database with whatever
biases that that has about one point
eight percent of those self-identified
europeans have have a non-trivial bit of
African ancestry so two percent is you
know you are local ancestry method it's
certainly not perfect but two percent of
the genome is is a lot of the genome or
that's not that's that's not a false
signal at all you'll you'll see also
that that this is not actually this
certainly correlates with the state's
you know so the percent of the Europeans
with with some hidden African ancestry
it correlates with the states with high
african-american populations but it's
it's it's it's far from exactly the same
right so it you know you see that you
know Alabama Mississippi Georgia
actually have much lower you know lower
hidden African ants
in the Europeans there then you know the
Louisiana and South Carolina so okay so
mating is not it's not not done a random
there's lots of individuals from each of
these states I mean all the color
dresses I can pick up or a pretty strong
so the white the white states are are
well i guess like the white states yeah
so yeah so I should have mentioned on
all of these that they're out there yeah
we did actually throw out you know
states where there wasn't enough enough
data there there are not many Latinos in
Mississippi who are 23 my customers yeah
um yes so yes I like my comment that
your signs of course highly political
probably has political conflict
consequences and I would just tell you a
fat okay that if you do assimil if you
do genetic studies in South Africa which
is bounced racially charged
installations possibly imagine you find
substantial numbers of South African
whites with very quite substantial
Afghan answers from you and I'm not sure
exactly connection but I think there's
something come yeah yeah yeah no my so
my wife's my wife's family is your gran
actually and they her parents claim that
you know in Uruguay yet everyone is one
hundred percent European and it is you
know that you know it is which it's very
obviously not so yeah it's theirs but
this this is a lot of people right this
is this you know this is two percent out
of you know you know 200 million
self-identified Europeans in the US or
something so there's sexually millions
and millions of people out there with
with with with something a little bit
surprising there okay so we've been
working and I I won't go into this into
trying to date into trying to date these
these admixture events but this this is
all very very fresh about something not
really talked about this instead talk a
little bit about recombination so this
is a project with a de Botton student
chris campbell at einstein nick for a
lot at 23 me so so so
so we've why at the time these figures
were generated we had about 4,000
quartets across a bunch of different
populations and inferred inferred
recombination recombinations olive in
all of them with Merlin so we see for
example you know here's here's the
distribution of the fence / meiosis for
you know maternal and paternal events so
you would expect I think everything i'm
going to show you here is is well known
and you know this is essentially just
been kind of our quality control check
so far but if you build a genetic map we
see the same map that you know the
decode did you know up to a couple of a
couple of changes that we're trying to
figure out if we have errors are not
sorry yeah as in odisha will exclude
there are certain America regions
I don't know if we tried that that and I
didn't know that was known okay we will
take a look yeah so as I said this is
very much you know we're actually there
was a flurry of emails about this today
as well so these slides might not be
totally it today so this these are you
know so you know but if we look at
hotspot usage you know so it's again
maternal and paternal aunts wide usage
we see we see the higher higher usage in
for the paternal events this end and
then i should say if we run a GOI sont
hot spot you three cbcp rd of nine quite
quite clearly so this this this I you
know I actually really wanted to share a
couple of other things that that might
be novel here but we don't know if
they're true and sorry this fellow but
but anyhow there's there may be some
evidence of you know so there's some
differences with with these various
effects looking across populations which
I believe those results should be awful
okay well I'm going to end a little bit
you know a little bit early perhaps and
you know one take questions but also you
know say that we have more data than we
didn't then we can realistically deal
with we have we haven't been promoting
this very heavily but if you're good
with Google you can find this page here
that you know we're actually calling for
academic collaborators we've been
reviewing these proposals a couple of
times a year in the spring in the in the
winter and it's it's it's short it's
easy if you know if you have some
questions that can be answered relative
that you know with it without a ton of
work but with a you know with a lot of
data but you know we would love to have
some some new ideas to work with should
then say thanks to you know this a lot
of this was supported by NIH and of
course
are you much much more so by the
customers who who paid for the
genotyping and answer questions and so
on got Corey McLean eric grant join run
Nick follada McPherson Eric Lyman all at
23 me Bri LeBron kasia Adam and empty
and Chris also with the project
submission before yes is that a
difference when you're claiming
yes we yes we do we do we do see a
difference I mean this is this is all
conditional on the assumption that our
data is is properly cleaned out which is
not a hundred percent true yet but but
but yes we are seeing a yeah we are
seeing increased hot usage in males and
some differences across populations but
less convinced about that because the
sample size insert are not all large you
have ancestry differences between
mothers and Carlos systematically I
believe so but I don't it's it's it it
it has been changing every time we
figure wedding it's not it's it's not
quite there like 25,000 trios have you
looked for any patterns and like
advocate resort animating the ancestry
base
we have found we found trivial things I
guess but but nothing not refute I guess
is you know I and i I don't I don't know
quite what the yeah it's it's it's a
difficult it's a difficult one we would
come up empty yeah I'm just trying to
remember it I heard correctly so what
you did the couple's thing for balancing
you said that hle was completely no
meaning so was there it was there an
equal chance of having we saw we saw no
no difference between HLA sharing with
between couples and and randomly
selected you know / muted couples or
different parts of the genome or
anything else
this 20 feet still like ya know you
should sign up ninety-nine dollars yeah
I mean right now you're not going to get
your health reports back so you're not
going to get the you know the scary
information that i told you about at the
beginning unless you are smart enough to
look up you can download your raw data
and you can do with it what you may but
but you get all of the ancestry stuff
back someone had access to the raw data
whenever you yes yes this is this is the
cheapest way of genotyping support
properly and you provide some sort of
like no but there are there are there
are plenty of people who do yeah it's
not so hard to do yep I think a
pineapple or you know yeah so it's a
word so we're working on that it's um it
cuts down this it cuts down the number
of segments so much that were you know
that that would you know that we're not
seeing quite as much over you know you
you it looks like from our simulations
that you need I forget the number but
maybe something like 10 surrogate
parents / / position to to really
perfectly phase that on average or
minimum for minimum I guess if you want
to really ensure that you're not going
to you know get a switcher in that you
know in that spot then you need more
than a few sori good parents you need
you know something like eight or ten and
i believe so it hasn't been working
really well and I believe that's just
because you know how those scores
throwing out at two-thirds of the data
so just as I say you'll strategy is to
run beagle then germline to get
and then you're going to do long range
phrasing and then reface everybody and
then reappear yes that is that that is
what we're trying to do I'm advice I
might suggest that shape it might
automatically do that for you one step I
mean the advantage being that the model
actually looks up how habitat showings
of each individual to all other
individuals in the gift softly yeah I
mean so it's a weird in the army yeah so
so we've we've had internal debates
about exactly this so 1 8am it slightly
I mean the licensing requirements of as
have stopped us from from using this
kind of kind of full scale but there's
there two camps on this issue is within
23 me we've done a little bit of testing
but it doesn't seem quite as clear as as
as I had hoped when we initiated papers
but we might be doing something a little
weird you said they didn't have any
comment about the timing but then I was
sort of curious in terms of you have an
idea is it like something you're
thinking in the last 200 years our
sewers it's something like 10,000 this
is the this this is this is actually
something that the Russia sent me this
morning so um you you you probably have
as good of an idea of what this means as
I do yeah sorry yeah good it's all a
little bit last
so you said at the beginning at 1.12 a
lot of these is if you looked at the
snips some of them could have been on
IBD blocks and so then the question is
whether the risk alleles are really
separate risk alleles or if they're
they're actually just sort of implicitly
inferring that that you have that eibd
block and that I DD block has some wear
on it a cop called the snail so then you
multiply those together separately yeah
it's yeah it's it's it's definitely true
that you have to you you have to get
independence between these between these
but even you know but you know you even
now you're ending up with you know a lot
of Joss is having 50 to 100 entirely
independent signals take care of it so
so it's almost everything we report on
entirely independent steps for you know
for I think our melanoma report we do
something a little bit a little more
significant sophisticated where there's
there's two snips that are in pretty
high LD that appear to have some
independent effect that is not the you
know but is not total and we have with a
model that takes care of that but I
think there's only there's only one or
two examples of that yeah I'm curious
about what does the raw data look like
and how easy is it for an individual to
figure out I wonder if I have it I mean
it that it really is you know far as ID
perhaps chromosome position and sub
coordinates and then a little one oval
too okay so on the note before but but
yeah sorry I like to do it 22
Oh $99 thing and I got a report but
there were no error bars on the
estimates of frequencies mine is that um
yeah I've been slightly fighting for
this for for the last five you say it's
it's yeah it is it is true that there
should be error bars it turns out
statistics is very hard to explain to
people and its statistics with every bar
baby that's not user-friendly I guess
it's the four-day what's your ethical
consultation or making these decisions
on what's report is in charge or how
does that work God you know we have you
know we do have a really great group of
medical geneticists who you know lar
we're kind of guiding guiding us and
what is you know and making sure that we
do things right i think you know I you
know I I'm a little bit biased here but
we I think we actually aired too much on
the side of over consciousness all right
let's cut it off there now Hugh tells me
there are no final announcements so we
can do this all at once